[Musik]
keine mindestabstände keine masten die
berliner polizei löst ein protestzug
gegen die korona politik auf die
abschlusskundgebung findet aber statt
großer andrang bei spezialisten viele
menschen darunter auch sportler kämpfen
mit den spätfolgen einer corona
infektion tour de france unter pandemie
bedingungen die erste etappe wird
überschattet von schlechtem wetter und
vielen stürzen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten um 7 den samstag
sport hat norbert lehmann für uns da
reiche gutendorf von mir und wir
beginnen in berlin wohin heute
zehntausende aus ganz deutschland
gekommen waren um gegen die korona
schutzmaßnahmen zu protestieren
die gerichte hatten das ursprüngliche
demonstrationsverbot der stadt ja
gekippt so konnte die
abschlusskundgebung stattfinden die dem
oder vorher musste die polizei jedoch
auflösen weil viele auflagen missachtet
wurden
so sollte der veranstalter dafür sorgen
dass mindestabstände eingehalten werden
mit weiträumigen absperrungen und
entsprechenden lautsprecherdurchsage
auch 900 ordner und 100 teams die
konflikte verhindern sollten waren teil
der regel eine masken pflicht gab es
zunächst nicht
aus berlin berichtet stefanie dosch rund
zwei stunden nach dem geplanten beginn
der demonstration war es vorbei
der protestzug abgesagt tausende hatten
sich seit dem vormittag zwischen
brandenburger tor und über die
friedrichstraße aufgestellt um gegen 11
uhr los zu ziehen aus den
unterschiedlichsten gründen wenn ich
unglaublich unter diesen zuständen leide
ich kann ich gar nicht mehr zu sehen
kinder leiden an der schule
mit max geben müssen die wahrheit ist
dass über krone und dann die impfe die
uns allen jetzt droht die menschen
verfolgt ich finde das einfach die
verhältnismäßigkeit überhaupt nicht mehr
stimmt von den maßnahmen die gegeben
wurden familien friedlich feiernde
sogenannte querdenker aber auch gruppen
aus dem rechten spektrum und vertreter
der afd
die polizei spricht von 18.000 weit
kamen die demonstranten nicht dagegen
die korona auflagen der gerichte
verstoßen wurde
die geforderten ordnungs teams in gelben
westen konnten den mindestabstand nicht
immer durchsetzen die auflagen nicht
eingehalten werden
deswegen hat die polizei berlin die
auflage getroffen und nasenschutz zu
tragen hat sie in teilen sogar
ausgeteilt ein die die venus banken und
nasenschutz zu tragen
dennoch konnten die auflagen nicht
eingehalten werden die polizei
diskutierte lange mit dem veranstalter
am ende stand die absage gefährlich nach
experten die unterwanderung von rechts
sehr viele rechtspopulistische und
rechtsradikale gruppen die haben ja auch
fast alle aufgerufen und das ist im
grunde die problematische seite der
gesamt demonstration gewaltsame
zusammenstöße am nachmittag dann vor
allem mit rechten gruppen die stimmung
im ganzen friedlich aber angespannt auf
der straße des 17 juni lief bis vor
kurzem eine genehmigte kundgebung
sicherheitsabstände wurden hier
ebenfalls nicht immer eingehalten
mein kollege carsten behrendt ist für
uns in berlin carsten bunten abend wie
ist ihr eindruck war die stimmung sehr
aufgeheizt
[Musik]
die stimmung war natürlich nach dieser
juristisch politischen
auseinandersetzungen aufgeheizten viele
eine gewisse jetzt erst recht haltung
mit der gerichtsentscheidung dass die
veranstaltung stattfinden darf eben im
rücken aber es lief dann doch
vergleichsweise gut der warnschuss heute
morgen den die polizei gesendet hat mit
dieser entschlossenen auflösung der
demonstration der ist hier bei der
kundgebung am nachmittag deutlich
angekommen immer wieder gab es ansagen
vom veranstalter zwischen den reden dass
die teilnehmer auseinander rücken sollen
weil sonst eben auch hier der abbruch
droht und dem sind auch die teilnehmer
hier weitgehend gefolgt deswegen ist
unser eindruck gerade jetzt von der
kundgebung dass sie relativ relativ
ruhig abgelaufen ist aber es gab noch
die 300 festnahmen und da hat die
polizei im serien schlossen auf
flaschenwürfe reagiert darauf einzelne
gefangenenbefreiung also wir merken das
war eine eine mischung aus offensive und
zurückhaltend vorgehen der polizei bei
der demo anfang august gab es riesige
unterschiede bei den zahlenangaben
die polizei sprach von 20.000 die
teilnehmer von millionen war das heute
auch so
also wir haben heute auf der bühne
häufiger mal niedrige zahlen gehört die
deutlich näher an den polizeischätzungen
waren aber es sind natürlich auch wieder
von millionen die rede gewesen
man kann sich das mal so überlegen hier
in berlin werden es mal nachgerechnet
werden bisschen kämpfen hans reuter
platz über das brandenburger tor weit
hinaus bis zum alexanderplatz 7km
müssten die menschen hier eng an eng
stehen so wie bei einem rockkonzert in
der ersten reihe
dann würde man eine million menschen
zusammenbringen und das war hier
wirklich beim besten willen heute nicht
der fall absolut nicht also eine
millionenzahl ist komplett aus der luft
gegriffen er 20 30.000 vielen dank für
die einordnung carsten behrendt schauen
wir auf die krone lage in deutschland
die zahl der gemeldeten neuinfektionen
geht leicht zurück im schnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 1300 menschen neu angesteckt
gestern waren es noch 1300 30 und wir
schauen noch auf weitere zahlen der
pandemie
nach angaben des robert koch institut
sind seit märz in deutschland 9000 289
menschen in verbindung mit dem virus
gestorben insgesamt haben sich fast 200
41000 menschen angesteckt die meisten
gelten als genesen doch es gibt auch
fälle die auch monate nach der krankheit
noch mit den folgen kämpfen
fabian köhler berichtet seine ausdauer
fehlt hermann strasser nach wie vor im
april erkrankte der familienvater am
corona virus mehrere wochen hat er im
koma gelegen der 65-jährige rentner gilt
zwar als genesen hat aber bis heute so
genannte post co wird beschwerden
ich kann keine drei stockwerke mit unter
belastung laufen ohne last muss ich in
der hälfte einmal pause machen aber wenn
ich einkauf oder umfrage jede halbe
etage also von daher habe ich da schon
starke einbußen
strasser ist patient der post co wird
ambulanz an der medizinischen hochschule
hannover
seit gut sechs wochen behandelt einfach
ärzte team um professor tobias welte
über 100 menschen mit symptomen wie
anhaltender belastungsfaktor
geschmacksverlust etwa ein vielleicht
zwei prozent der patienten die die kobik
erkrankung durchgemacht haben behalten
symptome
das betrifft nicht nur die schwerkranken
patienten auf der intensivstation
sondern es gibt patienten mit relativ
leichter erkrankungen die dann zum
thematisch bleiben
spitzensportler mit der
leistungsfähigkeit eines 60-jährigen
auch zwei sportlerinnen die zum olympia
kader gehören sind an der mhh in
behandlung weil sie nach ihrer cupid
erkrankung noch immer weit weg von ihrem
normalen leistungsniveau sind die
patienten werden oft als ich sag's mal
in anführungszeichen spinner abgetan und
nicht ernst genommen die haben aber
ernsthafte beeinträchtigungen und
brauchen rat und hilfe fast 200 personen
stehen bereits auf der warteliste für
die patienten wie hermann strasser gibt
es hoffnung denn die ärzte sehen
durchaus dass sich ihre patienten
langsam erholen
im kampf gegen das virus sind die
gesundheitsämter besonders wichtig sie
müssen infektionsketten erkennen und
unterbrechen
sonst könnte die lage außer kontrolle
geraten
angesichts neuer corona hotspots in
baden württemberg arbeitet das größte
gesundheitsamt des landes schon jetzt am
anschlag
mehr dazu von petra auto reiserückkehrer
steigende zahlen sie arbeiten sogar am
wochenende brauchen dringend mehr leute
und jetzt auch noch ein neuer hotspot
mindestens 35 kobe 19 fälle hier in
dieser heidelberger firma und einige der
infizierten leben in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft hier mussten sie
letzte woche großflächig testen
13 personen sind positiv die ganze
einrichtung in quarantäne doch wo
war das virus zuerst das ist schwierig
nachzuvollziehen wer denn tatsächlich
jetzt hier patient null also der erste
infizierte war vor allem wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass das geschehen schon etwas
länger geht eine grün leitet die
ermittlungsgruppe beim gesundheitsamt
reinecker hier haben sie wochen an
überstunden angehäuft im vergangenen
halben jahr ständig auf der suche nach
kontaktpersonen von infizierten
das ist effektiv arbeitet da müssen wir
natürlich ganz genau fragen wo waren sie
in den letzten 14 tagen mit wem haben
sie sich getroffen waren sie vielleicht
auch noch geburtstagsfeier nicht alle
mögen solche fragen diese erfahrung
machen auch die studierenden die hier
kurzfristig eingestellt wurden wer lässt
sich schon gerne in quarantäne schicken
nicht auf die straße gehen sie dürfen
keinen besuch empfangen
ein gut gemeinter rat ist das sondern
eine behördliche anordnung in quarantäne
kommt und wer nicht dass alles auf basis
des infektionsschutzgesetzes und der
enge des kontaktes geregelt und da
wünsche ich mir eben dass wir
verständlicher machen können warum wie
die entscheidungen wie treffen damit wir
dann auch einfach mehr akzeptanz haben
mehr akzeptanz würde helfen dass die
menschen sich an die gesetze halten und
wirklich zu hause bleiben und damit neue
fälle verhindern
sicher ist die korona krise kostet den
staat milliarden
angesichts dieser belastung kündigte der
spd-kanzlerkandidat und finanzminister
scholz nun an dass eine regierung unter
seiner führung die steuern für
besserverdienende erhöhen wolle
es müsse klar sein dass leute die ein
paar hunderttausend euro verdienten
einen höheren beitrag zur finanzierung
des gemeinwesens leisten könnten
die linke steht personell vor einem
umbruch
nun hat auch bernd riexinger bestätigt
dass er das amt als parteivorsitzender
aufgeben wird er sehr für seine partei
die zeit für einen generationswechsel
gekommen
zuvor hatte bereits katja kipping
mitgeteilt nicht wieder zu kandidieren
beide hatten 2012 den parteivorsitz
gemeinsam übernommen
normalerweise machen männer revolution
hat die belarussische oppositionelle
ziel of ska ja gesagt aktuell sieht die
realität in ihrem land aber anders
frauen führen immer öfter die proteste
gegen präsident lukaschenko an wie auch
heute trotz strikten
demonstrationsverbots versammelten sich
hunderte zur sogenannten großen parade
der weiblichen friedenstruppen zwei
ihrer ziele neuwahl und die
polizeigewalt gegen demonstranten
strafrechtlich verfolgen zu lassen
nach brasilien wo der streit um ein noch
strengeres abtreibungsrecht das land
spaltet die frauenministerin dort setzt
sich vehement für ein radikales verbot
von schwangerschaftsabbrüchen ein was
zum beispiel bedeutet dass ein
vergewaltigte zehnjähriges mädchen
gezwungen werden sollte das kind
auszutragen
unter dem einfluss der evangelikalen hat
brasiliens regierung nun die
abtreibungsgesetze ein weiteres mal
verschärft peter theisen heftiger streit
vor einem krankenhaus ein mädchen gerade
mal zehn jahre alt und vom onkel
vergewaltigt bereitet sich auf einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch vor
doch abtreibungsgegner versuchen das
krankenhaus zu stürmen
unter ihnen mehrere abgeordnete aus dem
lager des brasilianischen präsidenten
ball so narr oder mörder beschimpfen sie
den arzt auch virginia will abtreiben
das ist in brasilien nur erlaubt wenn
die frau vergewaltigt wurde oder ihr
leben durch die schwangerschaft in
gefahr ist
doch bereits heute verweigern sich viele
ärzte es ist schwer hilfe zu finden ich
fühle mich alleingelassen sagt sie
luftballons als zeichen der solidarität
mit dem zehnjährigen mädchen
doch nach einer gesetzesverschärfung
wird abtreibung auch bei vergewaltigung
an ganz strenge auflagen geknüpft
mädchen sollen sich aufnahmen vom fotos
anschauen und die vergewaltigung genau
schildern
ganz im sinne der familienministerin sie
ist gleichzeitig pastorin einer
evangelikalen kirche
wir wollen ein brasilien komplett ohne
abtreibung stattdessen wollen wir mit
unserer politik die familienplanung
fördern
religiöse fundamentalisten gewinnen
immer mehr einfluss in brasilien in der
regierung bald so naro sitzend 3
evangelikale pastor in politischer
rückenwind für strikten
abtreibungsgegner dem zehnjährigen
mädchen wurde doppelt gewalt angetan
durch die vergewaltigung und durch den
staat der streit um das abtreibungsrecht
zeigt wie vergiftet das politische und
gesellschaftliche klima in brasilien
mittlerweile ist nach einem langen
corona schlaf erwacht die kunstwelt new
yorks zu neuem leben wie museen öffnen
wieder darunter auch das metropolitan
dream together prangt an der fassade ein
werk von yoko ono und appel positiv in
die zukunft zu schauen
trotz krise für die besucher hat die
neue normalität in corona zeiten etwas
gutes sie können große werke wie von
monet oder bangkok nun ohne gedränge
genießen johannes hahn ein ungewohntes
bild für new york in diesen tagen
anstehen zur wiedereröffnung des mad des
metropolitan museum maske abstand halten
fiebermessen inklusive new york ist
hungrig nach erbauung in dieser schweren
zeit
wir waren fast sechs monate im lockdown
das ist jetzt nahrung für die seele
für den geist hardt hat die pandemie
dass matt getroffen eigentlich wollte
man mit spektakulären ausstellungen das
150 jährige bestehen dieser new yorker
institution feiern
dann aber kam der locker 150 millionen
dollar hat das met in den vergangenen
monaten verloren und das ist nicht ohne
folgen geblieben
20 prozent der mitarbeiter wurden
entlassen insbesondere um für die
nächsten jahre auch vorbereitet zu sein
wo wir natürlich einen deutlich
geringeren besucheraufkommen haben
werden als vorher
aufgrund fehlenden internationalen
tourismus in new york zumindest für ein
paar jahre
schon am donnerstag hatte das moma das
museum of modern art wieder eröffnet wie
alle museen unter sehr strengen auflagen
des gouverneurs die besucherzahl auf 25
prozent
100 besucher pro stunde werden im moma
eingelassen
nie zuvor konnten die new yorker moma in
solcher ruhe genießen es ist schon ganz
schön wenn weniger los ist es gibt dir
die möglichkeit dich auf die bilder zu
konzentrieren aber das bedeutet auch
dass weniger leute sie sehen und das ist
auch schade
new yorks museen öffnen wieder aber es
ist ein vorsichtiges herantasten an eine
neue realität
heute hat in nizza die 100 siebte tour
de france begonnen und damit sie die
arbeit ja das alles unter strengen
pandemie auflagen weniger zuschauer
abgeschirmte teams regelmäßige corona
tests für die fahrer
die erste etappe heute bei regenwetter
mit vielen stürzen
überraschungssieger am ende im
massensprint der norweger alexander
kristoff die tour lebt das ist die
botschaft der ersten etappe die bei
regen in und um nizza nach monatelanger
trockenheit von vielen stürzen
überschattet wird der deutsche tour
veteran tony martin beruhigt das feld
versucht durch zeichen zu zeigen dass
wir versuchen das virtualisierte
da waren dann auch die damit
einverstanden sind die favoriten wie
immer eine buchmann fahren vorsichtig
und bleiben sturzfrei während es auf der
berühmten promenade sont les zum
erwarteten massensprint kommt
rechtsaußen taucht alexander kristoff
auf und an seinem hinterrad der
weltmeister max peterson christoph klar
der schnellste heute erobert das erste
gelbe trikot
peter sagan vom deutschen bohrens
croteam wird fünfter für den 33 jährigen
norweger christoph ist es der größte
erfolg mehr zu tode fonds im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr gäste bei katrin
müller-hohenstein sophia popov das ist
die erste deutsche golferin die mit dem
british open ein major turnier gewonnen
hat und der deutsche speerwurf meister
und ex weltmeister johannes vetter beim
qualifying zum großen preis von belgien
den siebten formel 1 rennen der saison
steht zum siebten mal ein mercedes auf
der poleposition lewis hamilton auf
startplatz eins vor seinem teamkollegen
valtteri bottas sebastian vettel und
ferrari enttäuschten erneut
so schlimm die heute in spa frank auch
schon war es noch bei ferrari geht
nichts mehr nach vorne nur noch zurück
der tiefpunkt lässt sich beziffern in
rang 13 völlig leer und startplatz 14
für sebastian vettel wir probieren alles
und haben lange getüftelt gestern nacht
natürlich kann man jetzt sagen es nicht
viel herausgekommen aber ich glaube im
moment das einfach nicht mehr drin
mercedes dagegen scheint unerreichbar
für die konkurrenz insbesondere lewis
hamilton der zum 93 mal die schnellste
qualifikationsrunde fährt poleposition
vor teamkollege valtteri bottas der auch
schon eine halbe sekunde zurück ist
dritter max deppen im red bull
ferraris einzige hoffnung für das rennen
morgen ist regen in den ardennen ja also
fritz walter wird da würde man im
fußball sagen im fußball ok also wegen
als glücksfall
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt
allerdings vor ergiebigen dauerregen an
den alpen wie es sonst nirgends so
aussieht erfahren sie gleich von terni
das war s für diesen samstag danke für
ihr interesse
das heute journal mit christian sievers
heute erst um drei viertel 11 und uns
gibt's morgen wieder um 7 einen
vergnügten samstagabend wünschenswert
ist
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter es ist ja bisher
einiges an regen gefallen und noch mehr
kommt dazu und zwar mit diesem tief hier
was über die alpen nach deutschland
wandert und auch im osten deutschlands
regen bringt ja und auf der
alpensüdseite sind gut 200 liter auf den
quadratmeter in etwa 24 stunden schon
gefallen
150 liter kommen noch einmal dazu am
alpenrand in deutschland kommen nochmal
50 liter dazu und knapp 20 liter sind es
im osten deutschlands in der nacht
regnete es selbstverständlich im süden
weiter und auch nach osten tröpfelt es
an der nordsee auch etwas regen
dazwischen trockene abschnitte an der
ems nebel und das bei temperaturen bis
14 grad im osten deutschlands und 8 grad
in der eifel morgen einem tagesverlauf
viel regen im süden weiterhin ergiebig
teils mit gewittern das ganze wandert
langsam nach nordosten im westen gibt es
schauer im norden an der nordsee
gewitter ist es also so einiges los
morgen das bei temperaturen bis 24 grad
richtung hamburg und 14 grad an den
alpen die kommenden tage sind nicht mehr
ganz so heftig am montag noch kräftige
schauer im süden bei 16 bis 21 grad und
ähnliche temperaturen in den folgenden
tagen ein schöner abend